community on tuesday the 20th of october
this is an application for the grant of
a full variation of a premises license
of the quarry bank in
balloons bloomsbury
um just to do some introductions in the
first instance i'm councillor duffield
and the chair of this committee
and there's two of my colleagues with us
this afternoon councillor butt and
councillor german
and the three of us will hear this and
determine this application
this afternoon um also in the room is mr
hinchcliffe
senior licensing officer caroline myers
who's our
solicitor
[Music]
our governance manager as well and then
hides bully and representing
and then we have three objectives mrs
martin
uh mrs eaton and miss this roscoe
who live locally to the to the premises
so how we run these committees we run
these committees um in the same way
every time mr hinchcliffe our
senior licensing manager will start off
and outline
the application in front of us this
afternoon myself and my colleagues may
then have
queries and clarifications for mr
hinchcliffe at that point
there'll then be an opportunity for mr
island to outline
the application that's in front of us
this afternoon
and again my myself and my colleagues
may have some
questions or queries or clarifications
when mr island
has spoken there'll then be an
opportunity
for the objectives to um
to make their statements if they wish to
do anything that they build on each
other's statements that can often be
helpful
and they will then through dialogue it's
not confrontational in any way
for um objectives benefit will be an
opportunity through me as prepare
you to ask questions of um of the
brewery and vice versa as well
should mr island have any questions that
he would like to put back or any points
of clarification
that he would like to make as well all
the papers that we have in front of us
this afternoon have been published
in the public record that's that's the
information
um today and there's nothing else that's
secret or hidden or hidden behind any of
that
and we'll um we'll kick off with um with
mr hinchcliffe unless anybody has any
questions in the first instance about
the procedure in front of us this
afternoon
no that's fine mr hinchcliffe um floor
is yours
thank you chair um can i before i start
can i just
check um with those that are attending
um that uh the the
um the coverage in terms of the the
video here is
is okay uh it's just that i i'm
experiencing a few
a few glitches i also
i also experienced that as well but uh
it seems to have cleared for an hour
i think it's potentially you chair on
the basis it sounds like
when you were speaking everybody got the
interference but i've not had any from
anybody else
so um there is perhaps a work around
with that it
which is that the scope of um going on
mute
for everybody once one person speaking
and and
switching the cameras off uh if you're
not
speaking if you if you're comfortable
with with that technology
obviously members of the committee will
we'll we'll keep
in view at all times uh if that's
all right so um what we have here then
is under
section 18 with licensing act members
are requested to determine
an application for a variation of an
existing premises license and that's in
respect of the quarry banking
on bloomsbury lane in timperley
representations received and there are
the requirements promote the full
licensing objectives
the following options are open to the
panel to the licensing subcommittee
and actually you can grant the
application in full and the terms and
conditions contained within that
application
to include any applicable mandatory
conditions or you can grant the
application but modified
to such an extent as considered
appropriate to satisfy any relevant
representations
and promote the licensing objectives or
you can reject the application
the premises license is required in
respect of any premises where it's
intended to conduct one or more of the
four licenseable activities
these being the sale of alcohol supply
of alcohol regulated entertainment the
provision of late night refreshment
this application was submitted by
malcolm ireland
of nathan's llp solicitors on behalf of
hyde's brewery limited
the applicant has applied to amend the
plans that accompany the premises
license
in order to permit the sale of alcohol
in external areas
the application was properly made and
all the procedures were correctly
followed
evidence of this is an appendix a and
appendix b
which include the photographs of the
blue notices in place
uh in terms of the background history
the premises is currently licensed
i've attached the license as appendix c
the operating schedule that's completed
by the applicant and it contains
additional measures which promote the
four licensing
objectives which is required by the
provision of the licensing act
and included below in this report are
the measures agree between
the environmental health officer
following the statutory consultation
period
so you'll see that 3.2 to 3.8 the
additional
conditions that were agreed
should a license be uh granted then they
would be endorsed on the on the license
the responsible in terms of the
consultation all responsible authorities
were consulted
of the consultees identified in
paragraph 5.1
the representation was received from the
traffic council pollution control
authority which is the environmental
health officer
and that was satisfied by way of the
additional conditions that were agreed
and they're detailed inside the report
and also attached
uh in appendix d the licensing authority
has also received three representations
from other persons
which is the term uh denoted in the act
all of those representations are
attached as appendix d
and a copy of the report and all
representations received have been sent
to the applicant
finally sharing just in terms of your
legal considerations
as with all licensing subcommittee
hearings conditions may be attached to
the premises license
where they are deemed appropriate for
the promotion of licensing objectives
they must be proportionate and not
duplicate any existing provisions
contained in other legislation and
adjust the
justification behind the refusal or even
the attachment of conditions
must be given to the applicant thank you
chair that concludes the report
and i'm open for any questions
thank you mr hinchcliffe councillor
german or but
any questions at this stage yeah well
just just for clarification is this this
variation is just for
the sale of alcohol outside as in
the bar area outside rather than
taking drinks outside which which
already exists
do we do we know that you sue thee
i i if it pleases chair i can cover this
in my submissions i intend to explain
the effect of the application if um
or i'm happy for the licensing officer
to explain it by the way by me
right go on mr hendrick cliff go on if
you want to
uh yeah the the application is for the
sale of alcohol in that external area
there's a
a red line that's been denoted on the
application form
and so as as a matter of what you're
looking at on the out on the application
is the red line outline there's the
within the scope of that area
uh the applicant is applying for the
sale of alcohol
there's no changes to the sale of
alcohol inside other than what might be
affected by our
covered regulations at the moment
okay thank you
counselor but have you got any questions
at this point
no
no no mr island
um sorry i was muted yeah no i'm on
stage thank you
thanks thanks councillor but
island you've got 15 minutes from here
if you'd like to take the floor thank
you
thanks yeah um i i will try quite hard
to keep it brief
and i said i should be fine to get it
covered in 15 minutes broadly
i just want to give you some general
background cover a couple of legal
considerations which i'll try and do
without being dry
and then address the representation so i
said 15 minutes should be fine do
forgive me if i do what i sometimes do
and get very speeded up at the end
because i realize i'm running out of
time
um okay as i said i'm going to start
just by giving you a little background
um i always do that because i'm always
conscious with licensing proceedings a
committee gets to see a piece of paper
that says what the applicant has applied
for
they don't necessarily get to understand
who is behind the application
what sort of premises the application
relates to or what the motivations
behind the application are so i think
it's important to start with that just
so you've got a little bit of
context for the proceedings um
okay in terms of who we are you've seen
the application's been made by the
premises license holder heights brewery
uh you may well know heid they are a
very well established brewery in the
base just down the road
in media city and they've been brewing
since 1863 and they've been operating
pubs for most of that time as well
they now operate over 50 sides i'm not
100 how many but i know at least three
of those
fall under your jurisdiction in trafford
um responsible operator advocates for
partnership working
that's something i can submit to the
committee for my own experience of
working with them
and something else admits that you can
also see from the conducting this matter
okay so fundamentally as i submit that
we're talking about a credible operator
who knows what they're doing okay that
that's the who
in terms of what the premises is it's a
pub and it's one that's been owned and
operated by heinz i believe for over a
century
and it's it's one of those problems with
a bit of something for everybody it's
got a diverse offering
there's a bowling green so we get
bowlers and there is a selection of ales
so we get ail enthusiasts
live sports so we get sports bands food
so we get the diamonds
and so i said quite a diverse offering
that means the customer base
is also very diverse we we get all sorts
we get dining families dogs
old couples young couples old groups
young groups and
whilst it's a diverse customer base
simply isn't really what you call a
tourist destination so it is in the main
the local community that we're catering
for uh we've had a recent investment
before refurbishment was carried out at
the start of the year
at a cost of around 240 000 pounds and
unfortunately for us that was completed
i believe we reopened in
february which i say quite unfortunate
given that the uh the pandemic kicked in
very shortly after it
uh all in all it's a good pub and i go
so far as to say from the conversations
that i've had with the authorities it's
generally considered to be a decent
well-run site
uh it has not been placed in the past
all licensed premises have
but i submit it's not a lot and in
relative terms by no means what we call
a problem pub and we do try to manage
those complaints um
it's not as well there's loads of them
okay so i'll say that that's just a bit
about
what the premises is that the
application relates to
the application itself i'm not going to
spend much time on i'll just touch on it
briefly given the question that was just
it's really straightforward and all it
seeks to do is change the plans so that
sales of alcohol can take place outside
what i mean by that alcohol can be
dispensed outside
for reasons i'll come on to it's really
important for the committee to know
the application doesn't seek permission
for the premises to allow customers to
be
in external areas uh we can already do
that and there's currently no
restrictions on how
we can do that okay and so i say the
application simply seeks permission to
dispense
alcohol in the external areas really
straightforward
in terms of the motivation for the
application the motivation
being really blunt is kobe 19. um
the general effect of kobe 19 on
hospitality sector is well documented
and somebody who deals with hospitality
operators every day i can tell you it's
been quite frankly grim
but one of the more specific effects
that has come from it with hospitality
is it's resulted in an increase in
operators wanting to make more of their
external areas
they want to do that because the risk of
transmission of disease is lower
outside than it is inside uh so that
means there's two benefits to operators
in using external areas firstly
it makes it easier to comply with
covered regulations
the fact that the risk of transmission
is lower outside than in size
tends to mean that regulations are less
restrictive outside than inside
so if an operator can use their external
areas they're actually less likely to
fall foul of regulations
and i believe there's been a press
conference that i just missed but the
tier two regulations are a good example
and they say no mixed households at all
permitted inside
they'll allow up to six people from its
household outside okay
so the regulations are one reason the
second reason
customers know that the risk of
transmission is lower outside than
inside
and that means there's actually been an
increased demand from customers
for facilities in external areas and
there is actually a segment of the
population that's developed
that will go out and use hospitality
venues but they will only do it if they
can be outside
and again being blunt given the
hardships that have been inflicted on
the sector at the moment we need to be
able to cater
to those people we can't afford to use
to lose them
just for the fuller understanding in
terms of um being clear on what's
changing as a result of the application
the main seating area externally
is to rear of the site overlooking the
bowling green you can see that on the
planet that we've submitted
no additional capacity has been added to
that as a result of covid
but in order to achieve greater distance
between the tables a small number of i
think around five
have been moved to the car park and kind
of sectioned off with them with planters
there's no intention to change those
arrangements as a result of this
application other than to allow alcohol
to be dispensed in the external area
okay we want to do that because at the
moment whilst customers can consume
drinks in the external area they've got
to go inside to get the drinks and what
we're finding is at times
that's causing congestion with people
coming out and people going in
and that's something that we're
specifically trying to avoid okay
and so the intention we'll have a
temporary bar in the external area that
can be used to dispense drinks
on the occasions that the weather allows
us to do that and that would negate the
need for any customers out there to win
those to the drinks
so that that's the motivation behind the
application
if i'm being really honest because we
were already permitted to have people
outside and all we were applying to do
was to be able to serve them alcohol
from there we didn't really anticipate
the application being particularly
controversial we didn't anticipate
objections
and we've got some of course not come on
to those
but before i do i just want to spend a
couple of minutes on the legal
consideration i know it's dual
but i wouldn't be doing my job if i
didn't just touch on them
i think there's two bits that i need to
touch on firstly and probably most
importantly
in this case um a committee needs to be
conscious of what should
and shouldn't be taken into account and
i'll come onto why that's important and
then secondly
i just want to touch on the general
approach that should be taken towards a
decision
so okay what shouldn't shouldn't be
taken into account when making the
decision
for that we look to hearing regulation
19 and section 18 of the licensing act
here in regulation 19 that tells you the
authority must disregard
any information given by the party which
isn't relevant and then section 18 of
the act tells us what what
what is relevant and that's it relevant
representations
means representations that are about the
likely effect of the grant of the
application on the promotion of the
licensing objectives
okay that's really important in this
case because in my submission
whilst it might look on paper like
there's a few different issues to
consider in the representations
there aren't and there can't be because
the changes sought by the application
are so specific
and that means there can't be a wide
range of things that are affected by
whether or not the application is
grounded
with each particular issue that's
raising an objection the committee
should be asking themselves will this or
won't this be affected
by whether or not we grant this
application and if
the answer is no then it's not relevant
and it shouldn't be taken into account
in the decision that the committee are
making today
uh submit to the committee that actually
means that the issues in this matter
are really quite narrow okay that's the
first legal consideration the second one
is the approach that committee should be
taking towards making its decision you
may well have heard this i
i may well be going over the ground that
you're familiar with uh i'm going to use
it
in the case of daniel waite versus over
a magistrate court
to explain the approach i have submitted
a copy of that judgment from the high
court
and but you don't need to have it in
front of you i'm not going to bore you
with the facts and i'm not going to
start
quoting paragraphs off your paragraphs
aren't you i just want to
pull two principles that flow from that
judgment okay
the first one relates to your general
approach kind of your starting point as
i said i'm not going to quote
the judgment to you but i will ask your
legal adviser
just to make a note to view paragraph 42
of the judgment
and what what stems from that part of
the judgment is that your starting point
when you're determining a matter like
this is a presumption in favor of
granting the application
okay and that presumption only gets
reversed if there are objections and
except we've got objections
but also where the objectives are able
to evidence that granting the
application is going to result in an
undermining of the licensing objectives
and to be clear i'm not saying because
this case doesn't occasionally get
misquoted
i'm not saying you need something
tangible or the proverbial smoking gun
but what you do need is more than fears
and more than speculation
and i appreciate we've yet to hear from
the objectives but i'm going to submit
to you having read the representations
and you simply don't have anything
before you to show that granting the
application is going to result in
undermining the licensing objectives
certainly nothing that's relevant
okay you have fears you have some
speculation you have some assumptions
but i submitted
that's all you have that's the first
principle the second one that also draws
your attention relates to the importance
of the views of your responsible
authorities and again
just to emphasize the point i'll ask
your legal advisor to make a note to
look at paragraph 55
of the judgement and what sentence is
that your responsible authorities are
your experts
okay your police are experts in crime
and disorder uh your environmental
health department your experts in
relation to noise nuisance
your experts have all received a copy of
this application and subject to the
conditions we've agreed with your
environmental health department that
helped them on to
your experts have no objections to this
application being granted
and that's because they don't believe
that to grant the application is going
to result in undermining the licensing
objectives
what this judgment tells you is that as
a committee you need to attach a lot of
weight to that okay
so that's the legal position and the
representations i'll start with
environmental health you've seen we
initially had an objection
and that was something we were drawn on
the basis of those conditions we've
agreed i think it's probably worth a
quick
look through those conditions because
despite everything that i've just said
some of those conditions that we've
agreed
go further than what's relevant to the
variation application
we've agreed them simply in the spirit
of the partnership working but i say
it's worth making it clear to the
committee
and you can find those commission
conditions on page 57
of your reports and i said i just very
briefly flick through them
uh being conscious of time okay first
one
nice music and associated sources must
not be audible to such an extent it
constitutes a nuisance
that's not relevant okay we've not
applied to change anything relating to
music
but it's a standard condition that your
environmental health officer wanted his
partnership working his give and take
we're happy to accept it um next one
doors and windows on the premises will
be closed after 11 o'clock again not
relevant it doesn't relate to anything
that we've applied to change
but it's sensible and we've no objection
to accepting sensible conditions so
we're happy to agree
um there's a condition saying that
notices need to be replaced to exit
there is one on the premises license
already that this is
this is to replace i think it's
condition eight
and in essence this is one of the
environmental health offices of standard
conditions the wording has changed
they wanted the updated wording we're
happy to extend
external areas beyond nine obviously
relevant goes right to the heart of the
matter
uh we proposed ten o'clock in the
application environmental health officer
one to nine
it's not our ideal uh but we accept it
we're having to compromise
again it's partnership working there's a
condition saying tables and chairs one
bit in the external areas in certain
parts
um you could probably have an argument
about whether or not this is relevant
because at the moment we can put tables
and chairs where we like
um but the environmental health while we
wanted to ensure
we couldn't put furniture and have
customers lingering in the areas that
were closest to residences
and again it's sensible so we're happy
to agree sensible conditions
a condition saying no regulated
entertainment not really relevant would
not apply for any regulated
entertainment but we have no intentions
to do it
so we'll have to accept it and then
finally we have to submit
a noise management plan prior to
commencing sales of alcohol external
areas again it's relevant
it basically allows us to keep the
situation under review with the
environmental health department and it
means we can deal with the
with the fire points if you will any
detail relating to the measures we take
uh for sound attenuation
that's what we've agreed with the
environmental health officer and i say i
hope you can see we've actually gone
quite a bit further than we could have
been compelled to legally
but as i said very much in this spirit
experience of partnership working
we did uh endeavor to engage with the
three resident objects as well we sent a
letter to each objective through the
licensing authority
uh inviting them to engage in advising
the conditions that we agreed
with agreed with environmental health uh
we had no response from one of them and
i'm not this isn't critical i'm not
criticizing for this
uh we had two responses indicating that
they very much wanted to maintain their
objection i said that
that's fine um but because traffic is
one of the licensing authorities that
for gdpr purposes doesn't give contact
details and addresses for the resident
objectives to the applications we
couldn't really go much further than
that
um okay there isn't objections
themselves
i'm not going to go through an online
downline because if i did i would spend
a lot of time telling the committees
about things that aren't relevant
um and large parts of what's in the
representation aren't relevant to these
proceedings
i'm not saying they don't identify
issues because they do and we accept
that
and i've had conversations with my
client and i can show the committee that
should the people that have submitted
them be happy towards having contact
details and making contact
we will contact them we'll listen to the
concerns that we've got and where it's
possible we will do something about
those concerns
but so far as these proceedings are
concerned this isn't a review
it's a variation that means our
consideration is limited to the things
that about the likely effect of granting
the application
a comment that noise can't can be heard
from inside the public 11 o'clock isn't
relevant um
sorry at one o'clock in the morning it's
not really we're not applying to change
anything in the pub
and we're not on what we are applying to
change outside we're limiting to nine
o'clock
uh a comment that tables have been
placed on the car park there might
expand in the drinking area
it's not relevant we don't need to
change the premises license to move
furniture on the car part
and indeed we're not planning to do so
the only thing that is
relevant is an assertion that to allow
service of alcohol outside
would increase noise level and it is
relevant but in my submission it's not
substantiated
okay and it's an assumption people can
already drink out there
and i'll ask the committee why it would
automatically cause more noise
if alcohol can be sensitive out there it
wouldn't and there's nothing before the
committee
to suggest that it would submit to the
the conditions that we've agreed
with your environmental health
department they are more than
appropriate and proportionate
uh to offset any potential for an
increase in nuisance that could stem
from what in reality is a relatively
small change to the license uh chair
that they're my submissions
and i suppose we're gonna try to pull it
together broadly speaking
um i submit that what we're asking for
is a small change to the license
and we're not asking for something
unreasonable that's taking activities
into the small hours of the morning and
there's no reason in law to deny the
application because there's a
presumption in favor of grant
and nothing before the committee to
demonstrate what granting the
application will result in undermining
the licensing objectives
and there's no practical reason to deny
it either because what we're asking to
be able to do
uh whilst it's something we can't do at
present but there's nothing to say it's
gonna cause nuisance
and the ability to do what we're asking
any distance in the external area
is gonna be governed by a fairly robust
set of conditions
and conditions that we've agreed with
your environmental health department
i.e your experts uh chair they're my
submissions
we are of course more than happy to
answer any questions that you might have
thank you thank you mr island um you
have
mentioned some things in um in your
submission
that obviously we as a committee are
highly experienced in
um just for um clarification for the
objectives
this isn't a review mr mr island's point
there is
is correct and just for the avoidance of
doubt for
any decisions we make and determinations
we make this afternoon
it's really important to understand the
difference between a review of a license
and the request for a full variation of
a license
um so if there's if there's issues with
the existing license
we're not looking at those this
afternoon and some of the things that
you may say in your submission and some
of the questions
you have some of those things we will
not be able to take into consideration
anybody can bring a review at any time
against a licensed premises
but this isn't why we're here this
afternoon and the other side of it and i
know it's mentioned in the papers in one
place as well
some people think that planning and
licensing should be one regime and
they're not
they're very separate regimes so there
may be things that you mentioned that
maybe planning issues that again are
not within the remit of this particular
committee and i know that's alluded to
within the papers
but it's just really important that
everybody understands what we can and
can't
take into consideration this afternoon
and i just wanted to say that before i
opened it up for questions it's for my
colleagues um i don't have counsellor
jarman or councillor but i've got any
questions or points for mr island at all
at this
yeah well i know i know he said we can't
consider them but
there is there's obviously evidence from
the residents
about complaints they've made about
activities in the outside area now
obviously with what they're what they're
proposing here what
the variation they're applying for here
would only in my view add to those add
to the
activities in the outside area or
intensify them
certainly at certain times so i'd just
like to know how the applicant intends
to
address those those issues and really
what what's causing the complaint
how many complaints have they had and
and
what do they relate to are they playing
music outside currently
or what what's actually caused the
complaints and have they actually looked
into them and done something about
them mr island can i
address that back to you please yeah
through your chair so
i have a course and explored this with
uh
with my client um so i suppose the first
point to make on
complaints is if there have been a lot
of complaints they haven't come to us
so i say we we do get complaints that
the procedure
if a complaint goes to the brewery is
that the complaint then gets put through
and allocated to sam who's the area
manager
and that will stay open until it's been
responded to one way or another so
it will either be that we get in touch
and we say okay we can do something
about that particular play complaint and
therefore we will
and again to make it clear there's no
reason that we wouldn't do something
that we can
reasonably do we don't want to cause
people problems
there are occasions where you will get a
complaint and it will say for example i
could hear voices in the external area
at seven o'clock at night
there isn't anything really we can do
about that we can monitor it we can
supervise it
but there is a difference between
nuisance and noise and
if somebody's hearing people talking
gonna be a garden to hearing noise not
suffering nuisance
and that's almost inevitable when you
live in close proximity to a beer garden
um in terms of volume of complaints we
have looked back and i said that the
the the varied you'll get the odd
complaint about right this light was
shining or right this delivery on
particular day made too much noise
in terms of things that are relevant to
noise looking back to our complaint log
i understand from sam that our last one
was the weekend of the fourth of july
and and that i think in all fairness i
would
tell the committee that pretty way
across the country i had a lot of
clients dealing with complaints
because everything was entirely new
there was pent up demand we didn't know
quite
how we were going to work with kobe
regulations and so on and so forth
that weekend was a very sharp learning
curve for everybody so i think that
there probably were things and
again i'm not talking specifically about
this site and there probably were things
across the board that could have been
done better in this site it's probably
no exception
but we haven't had a complaint come
through to us since that opening weekend
and it may be that one of the benefits
that we can get
out of so i say we sort of we've got to
be careful
that we're not sort of walking into
areas that aren't relevant to something
the application seeks to change
uh but perhaps one of the benefits that
we can have from these proceedings is
that we can
at least open the lines of communication
and make sure the complaints are going
directly where they need to so that
we've got the best possible chance of
doing something about them
so how has the landlord received any
complaints directly that you're aware of
because they're going to the residency
of and obviously they'll be saying more
about that when they
if we so i think all we can really say
um
council of german is that if the
residents are saying that is the case
we can take that up with the manager but
again
i'm seeing sam shaking his head if
there's been complaints directly to the
premises they haven't been communicated
to the brewery
okay counselor
counselor but any questions at all from
start island
yeah uh i've got uh three questions
actually one is just
initially just on that point there i
mean when you say the the
complaints have not been communicated to
the brewery that's not the fault of the
the public on
uh you know it's not following process
in terms of the complaints procedure
i i think it would be fair to say it
would be um
council about i think if there had been
a multitude of complaints to the
premises
that we haven't been made aware of yes
we will take issue that and i said that
that is something that we will be
raising with our manager
if i say i appreciate we get to hear
from the local resident but if the
residents are saying
yes we're repeatedly complaining to the
premises about x y and zs
yes that should be making its way
through to us
all right thank you um another point is
the
uh you're saying that you've not
identified
uh the seating in front of the the
the pub there in terms of what the
layout would be because
they could move but i mean clearly most
places do seem to have established
seating areas and
it would have been helpful to being able
to put on there what your plans were
in terms of the seating arrangements
because usually heavy furniture usually
you know and it doesn't get moved around
that much
yes council but it is actually on the
plan so we have we have a designated
seating area delineated on the plan
uh which one is that because i can't see
the same
submitted with the application so let me
just
um i believe it's page 29 of your report
chair
so in essence the external seating area
as is
it goes from uh it's kind of at the top
behind the side
but to the top left hand side of it as
you're looking at the plan yeah i'm
looking at the top left diagram which
seems to be a bit more uh
more special so that's the cartilage of
the sides
yeah the designated drinking area so to
speak is on the
plan to the right so you can see you can
make it out on the um
on the larger plan can you make it can
you tell us on that small
can you show us on the small plan there
you know where the dotted lines are is
that the area that you were planning on
having as the seating areas
no that's the car park chair sorry check
how's the
mud yeah oh no on the bottom end you
know where the uh
we near the bend
uh you know the bottom area
the on the main road oh sorry to the
right
yes yes so that it it's part of the
curtain of the premises and what we've
done is just put the red line around the
cartilage of the premises
but that's one of the areas that we've
conditioned to say that there won't be
any furniture in those areas
right okay so can you just remind us
where the furniture would be
yeah at the moment i said there's a
small element in the car park
so if you look if you're looking at the
um
so if we look at the small plan on the
left where it says quarry bank in
that's the main building and you can
kind of see
a bit on the left of the site sort of
left and above it
yeah and that's the current
drinking area although as i said in my
submissions i believe we've taken a
small number of tables about five of
them
and that's on the car part i think just
above that drinking area
at the moment and that i say we've got
increased the number of
seats but what we've done is we've
spaced them out more so we can get two
meters between them
right okay uh i'm on final
i think you mentioned about already
cancel the button i'm sorry i've lost
you again
oh i think we've lost him hold on a
minute hold on one second are you there
dylan
i think it just flows for a moment yeah
dylan if it's free yeah dylan
should it freeze again dylan put your
question in the chat and then i can read
that out for mr island
but have another go okay
is it working all right at the moment
yes it goes okay yes
yeah so it's just the final question was
that i know the uh
you're saying to a certain extent is the
outside is being used currently uh are
they
mainly sort of smokers who tend to have
to go outside and take their drinks from
that with them
we certainly cater to the smokers i'm
not sure and again some may be able to
advise more than i
look to be honest i think and again i'm
i'm talking more about trends across the
board
maybe than this specific side which sam
will be able to be able to advise on but
it's
what we're seeing across the board there
is an element of the population that is
simply saying
smokers or not i would prefer to be
outside than inside
because the risk of transmission of
disease is lower outside than inside
so it's a fair mix it can be dog walkers
it can be families
it can be couples it's mixed yeah
i know this is a bit of a difficult one
to uh estimate but
what likely numbers do you think are
experience from your past experience and
the patronage you've got at the moment
what kind of numbers are you going to
have that are going to be wanting to
use this facility
in terms of um in terms of how many are
going to use it i suppose i've made a
couple of points
i'd make a couple of points on that so i
think
probably the first point to make is at
the moment it's a reduced capacity
because whereas we could have people
stood unseated now of course every
service of alcohol has to be
to somebody that's seated so at the
moment the capacity to be a garden
is 80. um but i i did discuss this with
my client we would
really really resist any capacity being
put on the beer garden one because in my
submission that would be more of a
fire regulation thing than it would be
then it would be a licensing issue but
more importantly
the regulations are moving so quickly at
the minute
that we have to try and maintain
elements of flexibility because
we've really learnt over the past few
months you have no idea what's coming
next
i think the other point that i would
make on that is
one we've certainly not increased the
capacity of the beer garden
with no intentions attentions to and two
it's probably been as busy
as it is ever going to be um and i say
that on the basis we reopen on the
fourth of july
we have some pent-up demand and i say we
we've seen this across the nation we had
a lot of pent-up demand
it got busy we had tremendous weather um
coupled with that we then went into the
eat out to help out scheme which again
resulted in an awful lot of footfall
again coupled with the good weather and
it has tailed off in terms of the amount
of people using it since
partly because of what's going on in
terms of pandemic and um
and tear restrictions but also partly
because i say that
those attractions that were there have
been dealt with and were coming into the
worst weather
so it's probably never it's probably
been tested
at the busiest it's ever going to be and
i say
i appreciate we've yet to hear from the
local residents but as far as we're
aware
the only complaint that we got about
noise was that first weekend which i
think was a little bit um
of a learning curve for everybody all
right
okay thank you okay um
thank you mr island thank you members of
the committee uh we'll move on
to the objectives now mrs martin do you
wish to
go first yes
[Applause]
yes are you okay can you hear all of us
okay have you had any problems with
a little bit in and out of sound but you
could well i follow proceedings yes
okay right and there was a couple of
things i wanted to um
to just sprinkle um since the lockdown
the police have been called out three
times to the pub
fights in the pub
okay and that's all been outside um
since
this outside seating area has been
extended
um if you're going to have
more people outside they're not the
level of noise we have at present
it's unbearable you can't
you can't watch television at night
without having all your windows closed
you can't go to bed early because all
you can hear is and then it says it's
voices it's not it's shouting
it's swearing arguing
and it's just got worse since the
lockdown
they had this extension they built on
the outside
seating area in i think it was february
and then that added to the noise and
then they put the
carpark seating area in that's added
more to that
that's bringing it closer and closer to
us
and if they put more out i'm not saying
they will but if they did
it we can hear conversations in the
house from the car park
now um
the other things i'd like to mention was
uh in in
his letter he really sent to us um he
said there's going to be no alcohol
outside served outside after
nine o'clock is there anything to stop
the people going inside
and bringing the drinks back out until
11 o'clock at night no
that's right that's that's that's
covered up and and it also says on here
that
um there's notices requiring customers
leaving the premises
uh quietly that's been in place for
as many years as i can remember no it is
totally ignored um i've had
problems with noise from the pub for the
past three years
i've had um noise monitors put in
and i think if this goes through
whether i'd have to have noise monitors
put back in again because nobody really
takes
seriously of how stressful and it is
having this constant
noise uh shouting swearing people
peeing up side of your house your hedge
and fighting is just is bringing the
neighborhood right down
the landlord's not very um obliged and
he can be very rude
and when in the past when i have gone to
the brewery about
noise and things i've been to i've been
referred back to the landlord
not to solicitors or heights brewery not
to
take it up with the landlord
that's my objections to it i just think
allowing drinking outside extending it
all it's going to add to our
noise levels we endure in these houses
around here you know it's a residential
area and that's my that's my complaints
okay thank you mrs martin i'm going to
hear from all the three
objectors um in the first instance and
then we can address
um all the points in one in one go uh
mrs roscoe
yeah i'd like to echo what yvonne said i
mean i've
my family have lived um in this house
since 1939 when it was first built so
you know we we are
we always support our local community i
have gone to the pub
a lot but it is just unbearable the
noise it's not
you know i think at the beginning it's
painted is there lots of different
people going lots of different
um you know different clientele but what
we get at night is just
loud screaming swearing shouting
you can't sleep i've run the pub many
many times
like while it's going on saying can you
do something
um and then so maybe i've not been
complaining to the right people but i
was assuming that those complaints would
be locked as it would in any any other
establishment
um but it is unbearable and the idea of
encouraging people to be outside more is
is just
unacceptable in my mind
okay okay thank you
um mrs eaton would you like to
continue yeah my complaints are the same
as the other ladies
the noise is unbearable the clientele
that are going to the pub now
it's they seem to be catering more for
the youngsters
there is always arguments
we have had more fights we've never ever
had fights
around here in the 20 years i've lived
here
we've had four in the last three to four
weeks
the arguments the language is absolutely
disgusting
the wean in the hedges they go down
towards the chippy they use it there
and it is continual night after night
i phone the pub so where the saying that
the landlord isn't
getting the messages or the brewery it's
not true because we have phoned the
landlord the landlord isn't approachable
he
i don't think he is a very pleasant
person
um i was on the phone one night at
quarter to two in the morning
watching him from the bedroom window and
he was still
denying it was them and it is
but it is like the ladies have said it
is
unbearable and if they're planning on
um wanting more drinking areas
on the outside they're going to have to
have more tables because there's not
enough now
they're already standing all over the
car park drinking
they're not just contained to the tables
so i agree i think it is a really bad
idea i think it's bad for the
neighborhood
thank you mrs eaton thank you for that
mr hintfliff can i just um
ask a quick question of you please
yeah um this obviously we're not
looking at this as a review this is this
happening for the reasons that i
outlined earlier um so we
can award some weight to what you're
saying but when
it's it's quite difficult what our reema
is this afternoon and i get that
that can be quite sort of challenging to
think about
but i just wanted to talk to mr
hinchcliffe about the fact that whether
or not our reviewers
the licensing authority have been
involved at all of any
stage of the last couple of years with
the quarry bank in
terms of looking at any internal reviews
within the licensing authority
um to ask questions no i'm just going
through
as that was we've been discussed i was
just going through my
my email email trail um
anything like this would would normally
come come through my desk and
there has been comment from uh
you know the police licensing officer
but not not not to a certain extent of
um giving us information in terms of uh
fights so um nothing like that's been
included in
in the report because um we weren't
aware of it as a licensing authority
and but it's certainly something that we
would we would pick up outside of this
hearing
um as a as a as a matter of course
um the the the other element is the the
applicant has been quite pragmatic
in their approach um you know
they have touched on that the noise
elements which
um which um
arguably and justifiably are not
appropriate for the scope of this this
hearing but
we see them as as conditions um
and there are other you know other
options that can be put in by
uh by by the applicant to help deal with
these measures
um certainly from the likes of my cctv
perspectives i don't know what's
happening with the outside
um but i mean ultimately this this is
this does step away from
the scope of the hearing um so you know
please don't take
too much into my comments there no
i think one one of the things that we
have to do
um we have to look at before i open you
up for questions to counselor drama
and council and butt is that the
sorry i've muted myself sorry apologies
apologies for that
um we haven't had an objection from
from the police or from the or from the
licensing authority in this thing and we
obviously have to
give some weight some weight to that i'm
just going to ask my colleagues whether
or not they
have any any questions um for
the three objectives and then there will
be an opportunity for mr island to come
back and address
some of those issues as well so um
council of german
yeah um yeah i'd dislike to us uh
the residents um
they they've obviously made note of the
of the noise disturbance can i can i ask
uh
what what times of the of the evening
what times of the night
do these disturbances disturbances go on
to
um could i just go first
yes well now the lock down at 10 o'clock
that
they're all gone at 10 o'clock um and
they
take all the glasses in at 10 o'clock
before the lockdown
they were drinking out there till two
three o'clock in the morning
and the glasses were out there all night
but lately i would say at the 10 o'clock
lockdown
that's when the noise relatively stops
sometimes it can spill out onto grove
lane while they're waiting for taxis and
things like that
but the 10 o'clock has been okay
like it'd be still noisy very noisy in
the pub
up to 10 o'clock and then they disperse
previous to the 10 o'clock lockdown
it goes until 12 1 o'clock in the
morning because
on a saturday i think it's friday
saturday night they have a 12 o'clock
license
is this more or less every night every
night for the lockdown
yes sunday night used to be really bad
as well
and i've got numerous um old letters
here
to people field regarding the boys
um and dates and everything and you know
if anybody wants a copy of those
they're welcome to them
can i just ask kieran have we got any
record of any complaints from
residents about the establishment direct
to the council
that he's aware of what the information
that you've got available
is um is mentioned in the environmental
health
offices rep and i think she mentions
that there
there has been complaints um but what
you are not provided
is a level of detail in terms of um a
chronology and so on and it appears
to me as though uh the the the
uh the ambition from the environmental
health officer was to agree
those conditions and that satisfied
their school
yeah i understand there's obviously a
lot of issues outside the scope of this
there is yeah
variation that i think may need looking
at separately but
yeah okay thanks for that thanks to the
residents
thank you mrs roscoe is there anything
you wanted to add there at all it's just
hard on the in this um
environment to talk it's particularly
bad after football matches and and
sunday nights used to be terrible um i i
rang
several times saying you'll come up at
six o'clock in the morning tomorrow to
go to work can you please do something
with you with your clients so um
yeah so it so it's there's the sort of
10 o'clock
lockdown has really helped me sleep but
obviously
that's you know that's not ideal is it
i'll be a full lockdown after today
yeah can i just come in there chair
yeah go on sorry have you finished
counselor gentlemen have you anything
else
canceled but yeah counsellor but flaws
thank you
uh it was just a quick one i i noticed
that uh mississippi have just mentioned
the fact that
there's not been any police uh response
in terms of the uh
any record uh of the uh the the
complainants there
with the scene perhaps because they
probably look onto these
premises seen police or any kind of
emergency service attend the premises at
any time
only when there's been fights
so there's there is some record of uh
you know activity that has been reported
and they must have records
i actually have because i've videoed
some of it on my cat on my phone
uh i think it was the very first night
the rope and the police were there
um but in a pre
later than that it's all together i
think it's three times i've seen the
police go
visit the quarry all right i just i'm
curious that you know there doesn't seem
to be any data from the police in terms
of
well yeah yeah yeah uh
to counsel it but i mean we do have a
scope of time frames for the
this application so we're going back
here to the fact that it's not a review
application
yeah um there's there's not um a re
review brought forward by environmental
health or residents and so on so
um if there's incidents that have
happened during the scope
of the application being submitted and
then a consultation period
and then perhaps two weeks wait for the
actual hearing to be
scheduled on on on zoom as we're doing
now there's
there's perhaps a six week void so if
something's happened between
that period then um that then it's
almost impossible for
um the police licensing officer to make
that comment so
i wouldn't want it to be um bad taste
in terms of if the police making a
representation or not
it could well just be the case that the
the time frames have
uh have not caused it to be to be
considered
we you have only got that 28 day window
for an application
um whereas with a review you can provide
your evidence and then
you would have the option to provide um
evidence later on i think they call it a
day nova hearing if that's agreed as
well but
we're it's a different style of
committee this is an application
i hope that i hope that's clear i don't
know
may i just make it make a comment on
that for you
um yeah go on i i i'm just kind of um
we're we're getting dangerously close in
well and
i'm running this committee mr ireland
and i will give due wait and i know this
is not a review hearing thank you very
much indeed
i know exactly what is in front of me
this afternoon
thank you councillor but you got any
other questions at all
no further questions thanks at this
at this stage mr mr island there is an
opportunity for you to come back if you
would wish to
if you would wish to do so to any of the
um things that you've heard from the
objector bearing in mind that we are
aware of the application in front of us
thank you yes i appreciate that chair
thank you yeah i
i think all i say is i can see that
my client is looking a little bit
surprised and i think
we have two very different pictures
being painted
so my understanding for my client
doesn't tie in from what i'm hearing
from the residents
and that i'm not i'm not for one minute
insinuating that what the residents are
saying aren't right
i'm saying that there is at the very
least a breakdown in communication
somewhere
i think it would be remiss of me not to
make the point on the police
that when mrs martin was talking she was
saying it was the first weekend
and i've consulted with the police i've
had conversations with the police
i think the committee needs to take the
view the the police are well aware
of their an ability to put in a
representation and they have deemed
that what we're applying for doesn't
warrant a representation
and the same thing goes whatever
whatever complaints have been made to
environmental health
and my understanding from them i said
the impression i got
were premises that has had complaints
but was certainly not something that
would be deemed a problem premises
most premises get complaints of some
sort and they have the information
and they have deemed in their expert
opinion that it doesn't warrant a
representation against the
um against the application subject of
course to those conditions
i i think otherwise i i'd kind of
approach
responding on two levels from a legal
point of view
there's very little that's really
changed since i delivered my initial
submissions
the scope of the application the things
that can be taken into account is narrow
there's still a presumption in favor of
grant and i submit there's still nothing
before the committee
that would indicate to grant the
application would result in undermining
of the licensing objectives that that's
the legal position
the practical position and i've been
doing my usual trick
of communicating with my clients on
whatsapp because we can no longer just
lean across and ask questions my client
is
urging me to say to the residents looked
somewhere
so something's not getting back to the
brewery so
we we will quite happily volunteer sam's
contact details he's the right person to
contact
it so something's gone wrong somewhere
in the communication because i said
this isn't our understanding of how
these premises is operating if it's a
problem with our manager
if there's a problem there that we don't
know about it we need to be aware of it
so that we can do something about it
so i'll say there's kind of the the
legal element look this is where we
stand on the um
the specifics of the legal argument but
i think also from a practical point of
view
we don't want to cause our neighbors
problems it's
you know we're not an operator that
doesn't care we're an operator that's
been around for a long time and we're
not
an operator that wants to work with our
neighbours so by all means
we are happy to give our contact details
out to the local residents so that they
have
a contact with some influence that can
do something about any problems that
they've got
and i said that that's kind of the
practical answer if you will
no thank you mr island i suppose um
obviously one of the reasons we're here
is to make sure that if we
granted this full variation that you
would still be able to uphold
the licensing objectives and obviously
the key one here this afternoon is
around
public public nuisance about whether or
not
moving the bar outside in essence would
would add to that
level of public nuisance i suppose
there's a couple of things that we're
interested in on a practical basis so
obviously it's table service only
at the moment so i wonder what what you
see is the difference between
your staff going to the bar inside and
the staff going to the bar
outside of why you've decided that
you you need you need an extra bar in
essence because if it's
nobody's going in and out of the
premises only to go to the bathroom
because of the table service so i
suppose we're just interested a little
bit in them
and obviously you want more people to
use use the premises
and i think we will understand
the
principle of the life for the licensing
trade at the moment
but it's an interesting application from
that when we're looking at the the
public nuisance and the and the due
weight that we will
give to the evidence that is presented
to us this afternoon of
why you feel that an outside bar is
necessary really
i think probably there's probably
i was counting on my fingers as you as
you're asking
probably three bits to cover with that
so the first one is when we submitted
this application
it wasn't table service only um that
wasn't a legal requirement anyway
excuse me sorry um i think in terms of
the the practicalities of a bar outside
from what i'm hearing from
the residents i think that could
actually help because if you've got a
bar outside you've got a member of staff
outside
and that will certainly assist from a
supervision point of view which is one
of the things that
i think has maybe come out a little bit
from the residents
if things are getting a little bit
boisterous outside
we need to be controlling that um
what was that sorry chair there were a
number of questions in one what was the
um
that that's fine mr ireland i think we
were just interested in what the
difference that makes to your
business yes
because it's only your staff going in
and out
sorry chad it was just going a little
bit um broken up
it's okay
sorry chad so i didn't catch the last
bit i think probably the other point to
make is whilst
it wasn't table service only when we
made the application
the fact that it is now just kind of
goes to demonstrate how quickly things
can move
so even though at this moment in time
it's table service only
it might not be a week's time a month's
time next spring
we need to have the flexibility to be
able to react to whatever the throw does
next because i said
from a licensing practitioner's point of
view that there's no predictability to
it at all
and i think that's probably a point we
can all we can all agree on this
afternoon that um
it's very very challenging for you at
the at the current
time um counselor german or counsellor
but
do you have any other questions at this
stage at all before we
um move into a summing up period
no i'll find that no further question a
lot thank you
no no further question no thank you
um from the three objectives if this if
before
um i leave it to mr island to finish the
summing up is there anything else that
you would like us to take into
consideration this afternoon or anything
else you'd
you'd like to add to the information
that you've already
given us at all mrs martin
um now i think that's it that covers it
thanks very much
mrs roscoe all right and mrs eaton
okay thank you um mr island if you'd
like to finish
something up and then i'll explain what
happens next thank you
yeah thank you chad i think
i mean it's summing up it it it is
saying fundamentally what i've already
said
there are i think we didn't necessarily
anticipate this at the
start of the hearing but i think it's
become clear as the hearing has gone on
there are two elements to this
there is the legal element in terms of
what do we do about this application and
i'll submit to commit to the committee
in that sense
that there isn't anything changed since
i deliver my submissions
and it's a very narrow set of
issues that you can take into account
and you have nothing before you to show
that granting the ability to dispense
alcohol outside
um it is going to result in an
undermining of the licensing objectives
that said uh i say i think it has become
clear there's also a practical
element to this there's things that i i
i'm confident we were unaware of
and i speak more speak more from my
client there than myself and
that we need to we need to examine and
we we need to do something about
and to that end i say i i've checked
with sam i will
send his contact details through
licensing
to be distributed to the local residents
whether it's a matter of look we need to
get together and we need to have a
meeting to explore exactly what um
what's been going on that we're not
aware of or whether it's just a matter
of look
if you have problems here's the number
that you
you contact so that we can do something
about it and but i say
it's right to say that and it's right
the residents understand that but it is
almost quite aside
from the legal points that surround the
arguments around this application
thank you thank you so um just to
let you all know what happens now myself
and my colleagues are going to go into a
zoom breakout room
and we will deliberate the hearing and
then we will we will
come back um i don't know at this stage
how long that's going to take us
um it probably won't be within the next
15 minutes or so so if you want to
have a comfort break with that and then
we will just reappear
at some at some stage so um obviously
this bit has been live recorded on
youtube
our determinations um are done in
private but then when we come back and
give you our decision
that again will be the the um the video
will be turned
back on so um we will disappear out of
here and we'll
be back in due course thank you very
much for your time thank you
thanks
um we've had quite a long
discussion about this um and as
determination and there's a lot of
things that we're not
particularly very happy that we've heard
this afternoon
however this isn't a review hearing i
think we've explained that as we've
we've gone along this afternoon of the
information that we can take into
consideration
while much of it decide whether or not
the very tight
um application this afternoon would um
would undermine the license and
objectives
and it's been a very difficult one for
us to um but we are going to grant
the variation to the license
but we have a very strong message for mr
ireland and
mrs bradley is the president
even says against the premises that we
would need you to take
seriously it's quite concerning that the
area manager isn't isn't aware of some
of the
um of some of the complaints of the the
very near neighbors and of some of the
um evidence that we've that we've heard
this afternoon
um we would suggest that if you're not
getting
what you want from the brewery within a
very short time table anybody
can bring a review process we would
encourage you to look at your options in
that regard
as as residents i'm sure the brewery
want to resolve the issue that you
you have with
but we will grant the full variation i
hope that the rory can
bring some resolution to the issues that
the residents have
or i do expect that we will be seeing
you for a full review at some stage in
the near
in the near future um there's
information on the council's website
how to do that if you're not getting
what you wish
i know mr island has spoken about
the bradley's phone number will be
available to you so mr island if you can
get that to
the council and the council can email
that out
and then we could look through
some of the issues that are in front of
us this afternoon
with that regard we know that there's a
press conference going on at the moment
and we wish you well with your business
we just hope that that becomes
a very welcome business and brings the
residents
um what they need locally but thank you
all for your time this afternoon
i don't know if there's any other
questions before before we go
about that decision and
i'm just very disappointed
yes it's a it's not a review
within the grounds that we have
we would encourage you mr island mr
bradley to
make some resolution but thank you all
for the time this afternoon
thank you thank you thanks
thank you